تستمر في فرنسا احتجاجات واعمال عنف على
خلفيه مقتل شاب فرنسي من اصول جزائريه
برصاص الشرطه اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا
ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات كيف تبدو
خيارات الحكومه الفرنسيه وخطابها في
التعامل مع الاحتجاجات والى اي مدى تملك
القياده والمؤسسات السياسيه الفرنسيه فرصه
احتوائها وايجاد حلولا جذريه لها في اي
سياق يمكن ان نضع هذه الموجه الجديده من
الاحتجاجات واي علاقه لها باخرى سابقه
كما ان نرى شخصيه نائل هذا الشاب البالغ
من العمر السابع عشره اذا لم يكن لديه
صلاحيه قياده السياره وكان يخالف النظام
العام
وارتكب اثنتي عشره مخالفه من قبل في سن
السابعه عشره في المقام الاول المهم
بالنسبه الى الشرطه الفرنسيه هو احلال
النظام والهدوء في الدواحي ليس موجود
ليدافع عن نفسه ولا بد ان نحترم هذا
الوفاه هذا الرجل الذي اغتيل من حيث مبدا
ليس لديه سجل اجرامي سابق كما قالت بعض
شبكات التلفزيون هناك انعدام كبير لثقه
بين جزء كبير من مواطني مناطق الضواحي
والنظام السياسي وخاصه مع الشرطه دائما
يرفعون شعار بان الشرطه تقتل لولا مثلا لم
يكن هذا الشريط الفيديو من المؤكد ان ربما
كانت العمليه تمر بسلام والشرطي يقول بانه
كان في عمليه الدفاع على على النفس
[موسيقى]
نتحدث عن هجمات على الجمهوريه الفرنسيه
وهناك تفلت واشخاص يتصرفون كقطاع طرق في
بعض الاحيان جرى حرق الفي سياره بالامس
دمرت مئات المباني في تقشير والهجوم على
المحلات غير مقبول
ويمكن قبول التدمير الممتلكات العامه
الاعمال الشغب تنتقل بشكل بحث
يحاولون اجتياز بعض العقبات وبالتالي
يسمحون
فاعلين سلبيين قارب الامنيه الكبيره جدا
التي تم حتى المبالغه فيها تدل في النهايه
لانه بقي النظام السياسي في فرنسا الحكومه
الفرنسيه ما زالت الى حد الان رغم دعوات
التهدئه من قبل بعض الوزراء لكن ما زالت
بقيت في نفس المستوى وهو قضيه المعالجه
الامنيه الرئيس فعل جيدا فقال للشرطه بانه
اليوم لابد ان تصدر اوامر لتخفيف الامر
وتهدئه اوضاع امام هذه الاحداث اتخذنا
القرار بالغاء عدد من الفعاليات والانشطه
والتجمعات في البلديات والمناطق والمؤسسات
الحساسه بعموم البلاد من اجل حمايه
مواطنين
الاحداث في الايام القليله الماضيه هي غير
مرتبطه اي ارتباط بمساله السترات الصفراء
في هذه المرحله في فرنسا يجب اللجوء الى
التكسير والحرق لرفع الصوت بالنسبه الى
موضوع السترات الصفراء انتقل الموضوع الى
اعمال عنفيه في بعض الاحيان من رجال
الشرطه وفي بعض الاحيان من الطابور خامس
منذ السينا بين السترات الصفراء لابد من
تغيير هذه القانون القانون الذي يسمح
يعطيك السلطه كبيره للشرطه لاستخدام
الاسلحه بحيث لا يسمح للشرطه بان يطلق
النار كما يشاء بل ينبغي ان يطلق النار
فقط على عجلات السياره وليس على الشخص
لابد العوده الى مشكله التدريب كما تعلمون
في فرنسا لدينا جندارنه والشرطه وليس هناك
اي قتيل بين ايد بايدي جندرمه وزير
الداخليه اعطانا تصريح مهم قال ان الثلثي
الشباب الموقوفين يعني هم اصلا مراهقين
الاشياء الشعب الذي يتظاهر المراهق هو يرى
في نفسها انه يمكن ان يكون هو نائل في
المستقبل ولذلك يعني هذا التظاهر العنيف
في النهايه وكانه هو اللغه الوحيده
المتبقيه بالنسبه لهؤلاء الشباب